[music]
I'm pleased to have Now Live on the Rich
and Show Long raiders executive Now of
cbs Sports Part of the PAP Just like me
and the rest of Us Amy trk How are you
Amy Good morning to you Rich Good
morning Always Always  A pleasure to
Speak with you on air or otherwise But I
think I just heard you do Two things
Yes Little
frighten FR That's the way The players
refer to All of Us in the Media not in
Media I Just give My opinion it i refuse
to Accept  I Just give My opinion Amy
You're On A Round Table All female issue
oriented Sports Show on the cbs Sports
Network You're doing Studio shows doing
Panel discussions your Media How about that
that cbs all Women We Need to talk
Show Pretty Cool H  That's What It's
called We Need to talk Yes We do well
You and I Need to talk Because The
meeting
ofs To and
Fans He about an owners meeting in
Downtown New York In the Middle
of the season What goes Down in a
Fall meeting  and Why do all the owners
Need to Meet In the Middle of a Season
well there's Two answers to that really
First it's not a specially scheduled
it's not a Special meeting It's
specially scheduled Fall mee is regularly
scheduled Ann mee occurs
octans The enti I was with  the raiders
those years I scratched Head and Said
Why do we have to do This in October
Because As You Know Rich It's a lot
harder to get to these places For The
Clubs on the West Coast than It is those
located on East So what Will  Go
Down Tomorrow What happens everyone
does Get
together matters on the agenda of course is
Sale of the bills Now by the time it
gets to the floor of the leag For a vote
thate is a formality rather perfunctory
that Sale Will have been scrubbed and
scrubbed and scrubbed  by League Staff
and vetted before it Ever gets to the
Finance committee The Finance committee
then votes and by the time it gets to
the owners essentially A formality of a
vote Never I Can't Rec a time When The
Finance committee voted inor of Sale
transaction  The own
As S of the bills
Will confident Will Be update to League
ownership on the Ray Rice matter The
appointment of the neutral arbitrator
the status of the Independent
Investigation When that Investigation
May be concluded be
discussion Concept Personal conduct
whole Does the Personal conduct policy
Need  to be revamped my vote I Still have
One would be
Yes The Direct TV Contract Will Be
discussed and You know i'm sure be Maybe
A Quick and Quiet update of the two
fcc recent actions one in which the fcc
opin that it does not like  The Blackout
rule which by the way For The last 20 to
30 years I P has been an antiquated rule
that doesn't serve Its purpose and also
the fcc recent acknowledgement that The
use of the Washington Team name needs to
be further added by the govern well
Let's Hit A couple of those Let with
that Last One Right there There are a
lot of Fans that are
wondering Why it's being discussed
there's a lot of Fans wondering Why it's
Still being discussed it Because should have
been Changed A Long Time ago And
with Mr  sneer in the Room How How How
Open does This conversation Get If There
are membership individuals Who Feel that
The Washington Team name is you refer to
it
ched I know am formal discussion If any
On The Floor of the meeting you've been
there you know  that whole Area looks
like I'm sure Will Be however some Quiet
discussion If not On The Floor As A
whole between and Among the owners On brakes
in hallways at
Lunch I've been disappointed that some
owners not ste
Forward Dan Rooney in particular Who
championed  The Rooney rule has been very
Quiet on This Topic I Real Dan isn't at
the meetings Now his is But there's
other owners As well but the issue Is
heating Up Now Two governmental bodies
The patent and trademark Office and the
fcc have expressed displeasure with  the
Name and and This issue is Just going to
Keep getting worse and worse For The
Washington Team it's not Going away When
you open the Dictionary and the
Dictionary defines The Word A derogatory
FL I think that ends ends The
discussion I
Understand use The Word but  the Word is
Offensive and it needs to be Changed And
I think This issue is going to continue
to percolate well in terms of Personal
conduct The Washington
Post had a story in today's Paper Mark
masky The Long Football beater For The
Washington Post obtained A Memo that  The
commissioner sent to All 32 Clubs in
Advance of To and
Tomorrow meeting and does Hit On
to Guess about on This New Personal
conduct policy read of It you is it
appropriate to Remove Someone From the
workplace Prior to an adjudication If
they are arrested If so  When in
particular should We establish A
practice of Leave with Pay Under which
an employee charged with prohibited
conduct is Put on paid Leave status
until The charge has been resolved
continuing on What the parameters of
such a with Pay status
ACC
C Time also in the Memo  according to the
Washington Post wonders If The
commissioner should even
be arbit in deciding This Stuff or
should It Be Put On A Third Party Where
do you Stand on All These Great
Great issues One of the things you Just
Said also is the commissioner EX and  and
Where I Stand on these Rich is
several Fold Whatever policies are adopt
Whatever Rules are adopted they Need to
be applied uniformly consistently and
with not a tremendous amount of
discretion and not
arbitrarily they also Need to be
designed to Restore The Public Trust in
the  League and and finally the League
has A Real Opportunity to Lead Here and
and to Foster some Social change so any
policy take
of interest of the interest of the
interest of they All Need to balanced
and they All Need to handled in a man
Fair toone Fair  to each Club Fair to All
Clubs Fair to
allers Fair to victim Need to policy
that is broad and broad and
not we have to be careful the Pendulum
swings Not to one the other and
interests KB Who I know you know The
daughter of Mike Brown  The bengals Will
Be on We Need to talk Tonight And I do
Believe Some of these issues discussed
The Show EX they discussed all in the
leag me today May developments today The
political need toir need
Trust
More female executives Within The leag
Front Office being H Ever  since The Ray
Rice conf exploded on Front pages What
do you Think The Le Action on that Front
Over the couple
ofs After Sharing VI on We Need to talk
I know
It's seen
Feedback I want The Le to As All
businesses do and H the very very  People
For The Job without to gender I don't
Believe A any to Because A than to
passed Over Because A If The Women that
The leag has hed are qualified and the
very very to do The Job
aref But My is and View is they should
beed Because they The Best at What they
do not Because they
Women Amy If If there was a certain
Raider owner Who was alive and in that
meeting Room today would He abstain for
thee would and a Sweet reference to
Someone obviously You and I have known
Door  in8 and You
alling throughout All This with Ray Rice
and Adrian Peterson and All these other
matters The leag is facing hasn't been A
day that I Haven thought
and
strongs
Go Back with Respect to the issues the
and man in has been handling matter He
would be enjoying Bit of a chule anding
to TR I told you TR told you But really
tempting
about hesitant to Speak Out quickly
publicly and adamantly on the issue of
domestic violence and and the fact that
there there cannot be a Place for that
in the National  Football league publicly
or or in a meeting like One That's Going
Down today absolutely both I mean you
May Recall A Number of years ago When He
terminated A coach and Look We Can All
tease and laugh about terminating
coaches But He actually referenced that
issue during A  You Know The issue of his
abhorrence for a suggestion of
violence would
Speak Amy Give me Give The on Ton Show
Where People can What time they can it
on cbss Network It is on I like to
California Time Because As You Know
being A californian everybody else
speaks in terms of New York Time And
would say 10 O New York Time It's on at
o
be on Tonight It is Dana jacobson Lisa
Les Sum sanders and Andrea and they're
going to Add Player safety and college
Weekend Focus Alabama Miss I think  they
Focus Washington State and I'm Not On
You have you have your opinions on On
Every Last Thing And I love that you
Share them with me
progr look
for you TV for Program and thrilled to a
Fan and and I will be watching you
regularly  thanks Amy That's Amy trask of
cbs Sports Media joining me Here on the
Rich and Show